ces rideaux baissés ou ses terrasses de
café est désertée en témoigne à béja
depuis quelques jours un confinement
généralisée a été décrété face à la
recrudescence des cas de coronavirus
dans la région un coup dur pour la
population déjà très affectée par les
deux premières vagues ici nombreux sont
ceux qui ont décidé de ne pas respecter
ce confinement non pas par choix mais
tout simplement pour survivre
en l'absence d'êtres financière de
l'état comment voulez vous qu'un citoyen
achète un masque alors qu'il n'a même
pas les moyens de s'acheter à manger son
commerce est fermé son état allait
fermer son activité est arrêtée comment
va-t-il trouver de l'argent
le minimum serait que le gouvernement
fournisse gratuitement des masques
nous n'en pouvons plus et vous pouvez
constater par vous même le taux de
chômage ici nos jeunes n'ont rien nous
n'avons rien dans cette région comment
vont-ils compenser ces pertes
regardez par exemple ce qu'a fait fermer
comment va-t-il survivre si seulement le
gouvernement pouvait donner quelque
chose même 100 dinars je ne comprends
pas ce que le gouvernement fait de
l'argent où est notre argent avec un
taux de chômage qui dépasse les 18 %
dans cette région agricole et une
précarité galopante certains se
retrouvent à devoir choisir entre
respecter les mesures sanitaires ou se
nourrir
ce qui inquiète le gouvernorat chargé
lui de veiller au respect des mesures en
question
sa seule réponse le renforcement des
effectifs de contrôle on essaye de
comprendre
situation parce que ça fait déjà un an
et demi et les citoyens sont étouffés et
ils sont descendus sur le dernier
leurs nerfs soit économiquement ou
socialement l'armée est déjà partenaire
avec nous dans les dents le tout ce qui
est comment dire
notre travail de nuit mais on a demandé
l'appui pour le travail et du jour donc
on y est on est en train d'attendre
encore la réponse le fait qu'il est
qu'il est dans les rues ça va y mettre
des messages vis-à-vis des citoyens
faire régner plus
les circonstances de confinement des
agents de police dans la religion est
inférieur aux besoins tout simplement
donc on cherche l'appui prix squattant
chance dans cette région qui compte
parmi les plus pauvres du pays
le manque d'infrastructures médicales
représentent un énorme handicap pour
faire face à la prise en charge de
patients toujours plus nombreux à
l'hôpital de béja le seul que compte la
ville c'est sous des tentes que l'on
accueille les nouveaux malades
en attendant l'ouverture du nouvel
espace qu'ovide encore en chantier dont
la livraison était prévue pour le début
du mois de juin
face à un nombre de décès toujours
croissant et un taux d'occupation des
lits proche des 100% l' agence régionale
de santé tente de renforcer ses
capacités d'accueil dans sept régions
désertées par les médecins
on n'a pas de réanimateurs médical on
n'a pas pris animateurs anesthésiste à
béja on a une équipe médicale très
réduite et qui est fatigué puis un alibi
qui sont en train de travailler de
cravacher donc devant cette situation
notre première première action était de
essayer de monter un hôpital de campagne
en dix jours en concomitance de tout
cela on a aussi essayé de monter un
service qu'on appelait qu'ovide mais en
fait un service reilhac au vide
il va nous permettre d'avoir quatre
leaders et à un premier cours et après
peut-être on va faire l'extension à
willy autres ya mais reste toujours
notre grand souci c'est de les équiper
c'est cette ce service là et
deuxièmement d'avoir des ressources
humaines qui vont pouvoir faire
fonctionner ce
ce service là une région agricole
difficile à confiner un taux d'incidence
dépassant les 700 cas positifs par cent
mille habitants à béja désemparé le
gouverneur a demandé l'aide de l'armée
pour renforcer les effectifs de police
insuffisant pour faire respecter les
mesures sanitaires
seuls les établissements éducatifs et
services de santé en sont exemptés les
déplacements de et vers le gouvernorat
eux sont désormais interdits